on May 19th airbag maker Takata agreed  to the largest auto recall in US history  the defect involved airbag inflaters  that could inflate too forcefully  causing an airbag to explode in a crash  sending debris into the car 34 million  cars from 11 different automakers  including Honda Nissan and Chrysler have  to have their airbags replaced that  process could take years  recently it's come to light that Takata  has known about these problems since at  least 2008 that's when Honda issued its  first recall related to the flaw and  prompted Takata to make changes that  would make their airbag technology safer  however most of the vehicles targeted  globally in this latest recall had  airbags that were put in place before  those 2008 upgrades since excessive  moisture seems to be the main cause of  the defect car makers are targeting  humid parts of the US like the Gulf  Coast for the recall so far at least six  deaths have been attributed to the  faulty airbags